moving on to hollywood's love affair
with hair
lauren zema has the top holiday dues
done by the star's go-to stylist
christine you do so many looks but
what's the look of yours that you love
to give your clients when they're
wearing their hair to an event or
something festive
i guess one of my signature looks that i
do and people continue to ask for is my
waves
my effortless beachy kind of california
girl wave that is what we all want
but you want to look like you just woke
up like it right right it's hard to
achieve
there's some effort that goes into
looking like you're not trying
hollywood tip yeah that is we teamed up
with celeb hairstylist christine simons
and hot tools
to help you create an effortless
beautiful look this holiday
season hot tools has come out with a
amazing product it's their signature
series one step blowout detachable
volumizer
and it works well i know that you
did some styles for us here today tell
me about the first look i caught kind of
like my party pony and to achieve that
we used the
smaller oval brush head and part of the
detachable volumizer
and we used the straight dry paddle
brush so look number two is probably one
of my favorite looks to create it's a
playful half up half down
so i really wanted to give our hair some
movement and we achieved that
with the smaller oval brush head okay my
family holiday zoom is about to be
watch out that's right girl and i hear
that you have a little opportunity for
our viewers during the holiday
season when you get this volumizer
inside your package you could find a
gold
card you can win a hot tools product a
hot tools accessory
even your own personal session with a
hair stylist
you